hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Korra Q&A I know everyone's
surprised that it's back earlier but I
think it's a good thing that they're
spacing episodes out just so that it
lasts longer it seemed like you guys
were all pretty interested to learn
about kuvira and what she's been doing
the last three years and I know there
was some confusion about why Korres in
the earth Kingdom hiding out there gonna
explain that in the next episode so
don't worry don't forget that the weekly
giveaway restarts every week so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on any of
the Korra videos that I post so let's
answer some questions careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet here we go question number
one Matt asks do you think that Zaheer
was working with kuvira to disable eyes
the government so she could take over
was she a member of the Red Lotus no I
actually don't think that she's a member
of the Red Lotus and I don't think they
were working together I don't think that
kuvira has anything to do with the Red
Lotus I think that she just saw a job
that needed to be done and she took it
on and things just kind of got a little
out of hand or things will get a little
out of hand obviously it's been three
years so there's a little bit of
explaining like we're not really sure
what happened during that period to make
her the way she is now question number
two spent two spent two asks will the
White Lotus deal with the Red Lotus I
actually think that they're gonna wrap
that up I don't think it's gonna be as
big a plotline in book four I think that
largely ended at the end of book three
the White Lotus hasn't been doing so hot
during Legend of Korra so yeah hopefully
they'll lay the smackdown they didn't
come right out and say it but it does
seem like the Red Lotus is largely
contained like either it wasn't a really
large group or the White Lotus dealt
with it during those three years
question number three death God Riku
asks do you think the top is a member of
the White Lotus yes I actually think
that most of the surviving members of
Team avatar at least from eggs time are
members of the White Lotus during book
three suyin said the top basically went
on a world tour like on a sojourn just a
trap all around I think we'll find out
what that is even if she is a member of
the White Lotus it's possible that had
something to do with some White Lotus
business that she was on I will be a
little disappointed if they don't
explain that and even though they don't
have a lot of time in each episode
hopefully we'll get like a Zuko Toph
or we'll get like a team egg moment
we're all the surviving team egg members
get together Legend of Korra is all
about the new characters but Mike and
Bryan did say that they're trying to
include as many of the old characters as
possible like they really do enjoy
putting them in question number four Jo
swamps and masks do you think it's bad
I'm more in favor of kuvira than the
earth Prince no they definitely want
this to happen they want your loyalty to
be tested that's why the earth Prince is
a total douche Mike and Bryan said when
they created kuvira they wanted to
create an analog of Korra like they
wanted a Korra type villain obviously a
bad version of Korra but they didn't
want the villain to just be another old
man someone who was on the same type of
path as Korra just in a different
direction that's why they want to test
your loyalty so if you feel loyalty to
kuvira don't feel bad it was intended
that way if it helps just think of her
as evil Korra
pushing number five Aneke matey asks do
you think that kuvira will go after the
Fire Nation I actually think this is
mostly going to be localized to Republic
City in the earth Kingdom if you
remember the board that kuvira was
looking at there was a bit of a gap
where Republic City would normally be if
you remember in book three the earth
Queen said that Republic City was built
on earth Kingdom land so I think the
kuvira is going to try and take that
back because of the way all the nations
try to work together
I think Republic City is going to try
and get the other nations to help defend
it so it will be like an everyone versus
kuvira fight even though Cora's gonna be
the one to do battle with her directly
question number six Cyrus Wadia asks do
you think that Korra will find Toph on
her own yeah she was definitely wearing
her fighting getup and it looked like
she was in the swamp somewhere so it
might be wherever she's been hiding out
I really am hoping we're gonna see like
a Luke Skywalker or Yoda
Dagobah situation with Toph like she's
hiding out in the swamp and Kor is gonna
be running obstacle courses with Toph
hunched on her back question number
seven full-time slacker asks do you
think that kuvira is evil or just an
opportunist no I don't think she's
totally evil I think she's heading in
that direction I think it's like an
Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader situation
kuvira didn't start out evil she just
saw a situation a way to solve it and
things got a little out of hand as she
went along I mean it's been three years
so there's a lot of explaining to do
but just like Anakin Skywalker I think
the kuvira got an idea for solving the
earth kingdoms problem that just
involved an incredible amount of force
so she's going to crush everyone in
order to bring them into line which is
obviously a bad thing but she will unite
the earth Kingdom
so she's slowly just getting more and
more evil without realizing it
question number eight Korra Olsen asks
why is Korra fighting in the
earthbending games instead of another
element I think it's just meant to imply
that she is inside the earth Kingdom
somewhere just because they're all
dressed in earth Kingdom garb question
number nine
Camilla asks who do you think the core
is gonna back this season kuvira or
Republic City or someone else so I think
what's gonna end up happening is is it's
gonna be everyone versus kuvira so
obviously I think that Korra is gonna
side with not Kabira based on the amount
of time they had to tell stories I don't
think that they're gonna be traveling
around too much with the army so I
really do think that they're just gonna
go after Republic City in Republic City
like president Reiko will just appeal to
the Fire Nation as well as the Water
Tribe and those people will come and
back Republic City so essentially it'll
end up being Republic City and everyone
else versus kuvira the interesting thing
though is that kuvira is a champion of
the people
and obviously the earth Prince is kind
of a douche so Mike and Bryan are just
trying to make it a little bit more
ambiguous like kuvira is better than the
earth Prince but she's evil and the
earth Prince isn't evil but he's just a
terrible terrible person question number
10 Korey asks why does Marco have to
work with the earth Prince
why doesn't he quit if he doesn't like
it so I think whenever the earth Prince
went into hiding that Republic City
police were responsible for his security
so that's why Marcos started with him I
think that Makos sense of duty is what
keeps him from quitting like he's just
so goal-oriented that he does what he's
told I will be interested to see how
Team avatar comes back together because
at some point they will come back
together like I do think that they're
gonna reunite even though they've all
kind of been pulled in different
directions thank you everyone for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do my next bonus video is gonna
post on Friday so what I'm gonna do is
I'll post a bonus video then I'll do my
review and that'll do a Q&A so I'll be
doing three videos for all the episodes
I know everybody wanted double episodes
the sea
but just remember the slower they air
episodes the longer it lasts
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Katherine McGuire you in an
Amazon gift card I'll be messaging on
your channel for details so be sure to
check your inbox I'm also gonna be doing
a charity drive for charity water in a
couple weeks I'll make a special
announcement but I will have some
special legend Decorah related perks
with some cool stuff that you guys will
be able to get they'll be like a
separate video explaining that so don't
worry since this is the last book or if
there's anything special that you guys
want to talk about for the bonus videos
that you just let me know in the
comments right now though click here for
my top 10 avatar villains and click here
for my episode 1 video thank you so much
for watching so let's all high-five
everybody have fun we watching the
episode episode 2 next week